hi I'm Ryan I am Jerry a lot of people
have been asking that we watch the
trailer for Sin City - a dame to kill
for him
dame to kill for which I actually read I
feel like I am part of the comic book
community on this one yeah even though I
know it's not just based off that one
comedy I haven't read all of them but I
read sin city a dame to kill for and I
read that yellow bastard well I guess
this one's sort of supposed to be a mix
between the stuff that's taken from the
books and then original material for the
movies by the way we have [ __ ] to do but
because we love you guys so much we are
coming together to watch this just for
you and actually it means a lot for me
to be I don't know means for you because
I we saw the first Sin City together on
opening night we were like what 15 yeah
we bought tickets from Miss Congeniality
- that's right because they wouldn't
allow us in Sin City the first Sin City
really stuck with us like this is I
didn't realize - right this very moment
just how excited I am for Sin City -
I've sort of pushed down my feelings on
Sin City - for like was it been like 36
years they've been talking about Sin
City - yeah since the release oh yeah
it's coming right around the corner guys
working on the strip you know did well
it was awesome gonna make another one
then Jim Rodriguez is like you know I'm
gonna make like six more spy kids babies
instead 6 months my kids movie is - more
machete yeah produce predators along the
way and then maybe maybe I'll get around
to it I kind of just said it's probably
not gonna happen it's it's like been way
too [ __ ] long even though they
announced it said they were filming it
showed stills of it I'm like somehow
this is gonna get canned and they're not
gonna be able to make this film anymore
yeah it's how it always felt I felt like
now they're just testing photos still at
a job I used to have I saw them their
name on production leads back in like
2008 or something as early as then
they've been at least whispering about
the possibility so it's always seemed
kind of like that thing where it's like
is it really gonna happen like you keep
talking about it the fact that there's a
trailer out has not hit me yet I don't
think it's gonna hit me until I actually
watch this thing and then I'm gonna get
filled with way too much excitement
enjoy have you seen if you were not
fortunate enough to watch the first Sin
City in the feeders at least watching
our nice TV and turn the lights off well
because the black-and-white experience
is so engrossing and then oh man it goes
we
imagery man that movie deserved a
nomination for something for visual
effects is I can't believe it wasn't
nominated as a snub because that's who
that's like the the whole since the
whole thesis of awarding things for
visual effects is like do the effects
help the telling of the story and it's
like yes they do it like it's a big part
of the art of this world so I'm still a
little sore about that
I haven't read every [ __ ] comic book
that that's been adapted into a movie I
haven't my understanding though is this
since city one at least was the most
accurate depiction based on a graphic
novel ever oh yeah it's like they really
brought it to life and all you've got to
do is peruse a few pages to get that I
totally have in that respect we're just
we're not even watching the second
trailer I was just talking it's so much
about why we love the first but that's
what I mean like I've had all these love
for the movie but it's like I don't want
to talk about it because they're not
going to party part of the goons back we
come back to that highway knees is like
I missed how could I [ __ ] this up come
on old man angina every voice I do now
it turns into Batman somehow since it's
only a minute and 20 seconds yeah it's
just the TV okay okay sorry guys if you
can't hear us it's because I really want
the speaker's pretty loud for this one
another Saturday night exciting is it
the zeenat again Marv it's another
Saturday night the power is on
staring me up how much I love you too I
just did I forgot josh brolin what I
gotta do - GG Elle's in this giggle who
died one of these days your poetry good
game
stanley tucci yes they're back gee this
looks like his shot better that's Sam
Jackson now Dennis Hayes
whether they kill for
since cities were you coming dries all
good
somebody chill are y'all come at all
I've never been so excited I've never
been so excited to hear somebody's
internal monologue yeah - right
[ __ ] man oh my god I haven't been this
excited ever when I've seen the trailer
yeah no I'm oh it's about time okay
every moment of that trailer was
exciting to me this right when Mart it's
[ __ ] flipping through the air at the
beginning it's like it's a barback one
especially after all the like wondering
if he would actually do the movie yeah
cuz you know Mickey work likes to be no
sorries movie that gave me my career
back I don't know if I want to go Joseph
gordon-levitt yeah who [ __ ] better to
get that Joseph gordon-levitt one of the
coolest actors out there oddly enough
it's like we know he can do noir because
we've seen brick ever so Oh looper yeah
he's gonna rock it man the atoms in the
Sin City universe that I was gonna be
way cool isn't it funny how Bruce Willis
was in Sin City 1 and Joseph
gordon-levitt whoo starboard Bruce
Willis and looper is in Sin City - there
you go
that's a cool trying yeah and then Jai
Courtney from die hard 5 is gonna star
in Sin City three
yeah Green is apparently Bo Miller in
comic book movie girl is after three
under eyes of an empire I've seen Eva
greens performances before but for some
reason rise of an empire made me go I
want to see this girl in more movies and
just seeing her in this like oh she
plays today me kill for no they said
well it looks like in the trailer I mean
now so many Dame's how cool was that
line just when Mickey Rourke said the
line of the movie she's a dame to kill
for like oh god if there's one movie
that's gonna say the title of the movie
it's gonna be this one and it's gonna
sound bad [ __ ] ass and Josh Brolin
taking over for Dwight yeah anything
ever for Clive Owen yeah dude oh that's
what confused me were actually read the
comic cuz I was like what the hell
happened to Dwight wise even balding but
why does he look like Derek Mears yeah
exactly
but watching this like that you barely
see Josh Brolin in it but it's Josh
Brolin yeah it's going to even when he
does horrible movies people are like but
Josh Brolin's Burt
[ __ ] good visual effects are probably
update it's been 10 years I thought the
most they would do is be able to
duplicate the greatness of part one
something about it seems like they were
able to make this look a little sharper
it'll probably be crazy to look at Ray
Liotta Ray Liotta Ray Liotta Bruce
Willis is back in this - yeah they said
he was gonna buy wine other credits so
we can there's a lot of [ __ ] people
people love to work for him because he
moves fast that's what pissed me off
about this experience
everyone's like Robert Rodriguez is one
of the fastest moving directors ever he
shoots his films in like 10 days and
then I'm like why is it taking him 15
years to come out with the next one okay
the thing is Jack me up about his
trailers so much is that whenever you
saw a cast member
you were like they're the perfect person
for the Sin City world yeah no not one
person you're like but yeah ray Liotta's
know that because I saw the Iceman and I
was like I miss Ray Liotta being this
[ __ ] remembered when Goodfellas existed
and now he's back in in a Sin City world
he's working Rodriguez and I'm like if
there's anything Ray Liotta can be the
[ __ ] again it's [ __ ] sinner Tarantino
movie yo Tarantino and we'll collaborate
well I mean nark was good but it's been
a while since he's done something great
but you know movie kula seeing this
Liam Neeson ah Sin City 3 yeah dude Liam
Neeson so much hope and last well at
least one of the battery dies driver
thank you so good you must have friends
tell them all to subscribe I have any
subscribe where are they god damn it